the suspect accused of a deadly ambush
on police in South Carolina bragged
about his shooting skills online but we
still don't know why three sheriff's
deputies and four police officers were
shot on Wednesday while they were
attempting to serve a search warrant at
the suspects home sergeant Terrence
caraway of the Florence Police
Department was killed David Beck knows
in Florence which is about 100 miles
north of Charleston was more on this
story David good morning to you hi hi
Gil you know what's interesting this
morning the alleged shooter in this case
still hasn't been charged with a crime
now he's in custody and officials say
there's no threat to the public but he
still hasn't been formally charged yet
the three deputies who were the first to
be shot were all women they are still in
the hospital this morning
and Gail just mentioned sergeant caraway
he was remembered last night at a
community vigil friends and colleagues
say sergeant Terrence caraway dedicated
himself to the community of Florence
just last month the Air Force veteran
was honored for more than 30 years of
service to the city's police department
he was a giant of a man but he was the
proverbial general John and I loved him
according to a senior law enforcement
official the shooter is Frederick
Hopkins he's a 74 year old Vietnam
veteran and disbarred attorney who
described himself on social media as a
competitive marksman shots were fired at
4:00 p.m. Wednesday sheriff's deputies
were attempting to enter this home with
a search warrant because a 27 year-old
man inside is the subject of a child sex
assault investigation according to a
senior law enforcement official the
Greenville News reports that Hopkins was
perched on the second-story with a
high-powered rifle that gave him a
direct line of sight down the street as
backup officers approached the home some
of the officers who were shot were 15
yards away
take for example sergeant caraway that's
his vehicle down the street white police
car probably 15 or so yards from the
suspects house which is at the end of
the street
sergeant caraway we're told was shot
right near his vehicle
Flores police chief Alan Heidler
estimates it took about 30 minutes to be
able to get in to rescue the wounded
officers using an armored truck it's my
understanding
right now that they didn't know the
level of firepower that they were going
in so the crimes happened in Florence
County but the Richland County Sheriff's
Department probably an hour down the
road was asked to take over the
investigation
John this is interesting the sheriff was
asked yesterday did the family at the
end of the way where the shooting
happened were they given a heads-up that
those female deputies were coming to
search the home the sheriff
answered the question this way I don't
know all the facts and I can't say right
now we're gonna keep pushing to find out
if in fact that happened and you'll be
right back telling us thank you David